So, we come to the end of the course and
all roads lead to Jerusalem.
So, um we're going to take everything
we've learned so far and combine it into
a narrative about today and the future.
So the grand thesis of this class is
that six societies control the world and
this something you can never prove.
Okay, but let me propose a theory of how
we can approach a truth. Okay, theory of
truth.
If you have a theory or an idea or a
narrative and it does these three things
then it approaches the truth. The first
is that it connects
the past.
Okay.
So does it help us put the past things
that we know that happened in the past
into a coherent story that we can
understand? Okay. That's test number
one. Test number two is
it explains
the present.
Does it help us better understand the
world we live in? Okay. And the last and
the most um important is predicts the
future.
From this narrative, we should be able
to make certain predictions about how
events should develop. And if these
events turn out to happen the way we
predict, then we can be more sure that
our theory of truth is correct. Now,
let's be extremely precise. Just because
things turn out the way that we predict
doesn't necessarily mean that our
theories is 100% correct. Okay? because
it's really important to understand that
correl correlation
does not necessarily mean causation.
Okay, so that that's a caveat. No matter
how well we predict the future, it
doesn't necessarily mean that our theory
is 100% correct. But our theory gives us
a model to understand
the past, the present, and the future.
Okay. So, with very little evidence,
I'm going to present to you a theory
about how the world works, a story about
how we got to where we are. And again,
this is speculation. Some will call this
conspiracy theory. And this is just
meant to be a funny class. So, take what
I say with a grain of salt, okay? Ask
good questions. Doubt what I say. But
what I'll show you is that this theory,
even though it doesn't really um make
much sense and you may not believe it,
it does help us connect the the past,
explain the present, and predict the
future. Okay? All right. So, uh without
further ado, let's go into this theory.
So, you remember Jacob Frank
[snorts]
who founded the Sabatine Frankus
movement. Okay?
and
um
he will convert to the Catholic religion
and he he will encourage his followers
to also follow him into Catholic
religion and also to infiltrate secret
societies.
One of his friends, one of his patrons
is Mayor Rothschild
who is founder of course the Rothschild
banking dynasty which we discussed last
class. He will introduce Jacob Frank to
another person named Adam
Weiss
Hot in Bavaria. Okay. In present day
Germany. All right. Now, Adam Weisshot,
he is actually a former Jesuit. Okay.
He's so he's a member of the Catholic
Church. He's also a Jew. Okay. And
again, um we don't have any evidence
that these three actually know each
other,
but this is a theory. All right. So
let's assume they they knew each other.
What they will do together is create a
new organization called the Illuminati.
And this organization
is what controls the world, the
Illuminati. Now there is a legend that
Adam Was when he after he created
Illuminati, he encouraged his followers
to infiltrate another organization
called the Freemasons.
>> [snorts]
>> And these were extremely prominent
members
of [snorts] European society. Okay,
these are intellectuals like Gerta.
These were nobility. These were bankers.
And so this is the framework that
controls the world. Okay. The illuminat
Illuminati was able to penetrate the
Freemasons. So now you have an alliance
of the of the Jesuits,
the Jews, the Frank, the Sepian Frankas,
the Catholics uh and the Freemasons.
Okay. And so this is the alliance of
secret societies. Now there is a legend
that what happened is that Adam Weishob
he was eventually arrested for
conspiracy
by the authorities. And so the
organization the Illumati has been
disbanded. It no longer exists.
>> [snorts]
>> But there are others who argue that's
not what happened. In fact, it was Adam
Weisstock himself who spread the legend
that there was a secret organization
called the Illuminati. Okay. So, so the
entire thing was to generate publicity.
But in reality, Illuminati was not
disbanded and it still exists today. So
why would they do this? And the reason
why is that secret societies like every
organization depends on publicity for
recruitment. Okay. So it's free free
publicity. If you read a newspaper that
there's a secret organization that's
trying to conquer the world and which
the authorities don't like. Then a lot
of people will be like how do I join
this organization? Right? And that's
what happened. Right? So the the irony
about secret societies is
they have a structure which is like a
triangle. Okay. At the very top is a
leadership. This leadership is secret.
You don't know who they are. You don't
know what they do. Okay. But they
usually come from um very noble
families.
We call these the 13 families. Okay.
Then [snorts] at the very bottom are
just the public members. and they think
that what they do is just good stuff.
Okay, so the Freemasons, they actually
don't know what the leadership does. The
key is the middle management. These
people, okay, these people are the ones
who are who do all the work and these
people are selected for ambition. In
other words, for power, they're willing
to sell their souls.
All right? [snorts] Okay. So when you
have different secret societies together
a major problem that you have is
coordination and the idea here is you
have different leaders and how do you
get them to work together also after
these leaders die how do you ensure that
the new leaders
are will coordinate together and the
answer to this problem is the idea of
esquetology
okay we'll discuss esquetology but
esquetology ology comes from the Greek
word escaton which means the end. So
esquetology means your understanding of
how the world ends of how to create
paradise on earth. And what I will show
you is that even though
these different groups have different
esquetologies,
there are convergence points which
allows them to work together. Okay, so
let's go over the major esquetologies.
And remember what's really important to
understand is that [snorts]
these esquetologies are often secret.
They sometimes change and the details
will be different. But so I'm going to
present to you more or less a general
understanding of different
esquetologies. Okay. So let's start with
the eases which is a Jewish esquetology.
What do the Jews believe? Well, the Jews
believe that because they disobeyed God,
because they worshiped false idols,
because they sinned,
they were expelled by God from their
homeland, Jerusalem, to wander the
earth, which creates the Jewish
diaspora.
But eventually, what will happen is that
a Jewish Messiah
will emerge to take the Jews back to
Jerusalem. Okay? and he will
reconstitute the nation of Israel. He
will recreate Israel
and then he will
uh build rebuild Solomon's temple. Why?
Because Solomon's temple is where God
lives and it is where the people of
Israel make sacrifices to Yahweh in
order to show their devotion to Yahweh.
So Solomon's temple is really important.
There will be something called a war of
Gog and Magog.
where basically the entire world
um unites against Israel. Okay. And the
war of Gog
will be led by the antichrist,
the anti- messiah,
the false prophet.
We don't know
what Gog and Mog represent. Okay. What
the Bible says is these are people from
the north, but that could mean anyone.
And certain um Jewish
um scholars have interpreted Gawk and
Mok to represent Russia and Iran. Okay,
this is important because of what's
happening today. Okay. But of course,
when it seems as though the enemies of
Israel, Gog and Mog, when it seems that
they are about to win, God will
intervene and ensure that Israel wins.
And this will usher in something called
the Mesig age.
When Israel becomes the most dominant
nation on earth, when it becomes the
light of nations, when it becomes
the light of the world. Okay, does that
make sense? So that is the Jewish
esquetology and most Jews believe this.
Then you have the Frankus. Okay. and the
Frankus Sabatine Frankas they make
important
changes to this esquetology. Okay. The
first important change is
the Jews believe that the Messiah will
come when the time is right. So most
rabbi believe that the Messiah will come
in the year 6000 in Jewish calendar
which is about the year 2040 uh sorry
202040 in our calendar which is about
200 years later. Okay. So still a long
time away. Um but the Franks believe
that the messiah has already come right
Zevi and then you have Jacob Frank. So
they believe that the first of all the
the Messiah is already here. Okay, which
means that the war can start.
Second thing that they believe is that
you don't wait for God to
intervene. You can you can accelerate
the messianic age by sinning, right?
Because by sinning, what you're doing is
you are defying Satan. It's Satan who
created this world. And by sinning,
you're defying his laws. You're defying
his authority. And this will create more
chaos. And you will you will reveal how
evil this world is. You will accelerate
the collapse. Okay? Which will force God
to intervene. And then at the and then
during the messianic age what will
happen is material pleasure. Okay. So
rather than everyone being spiritual and
pure we'll have a lot of sex. We will
have feast. We will live forever. Okay.
That's a Frankus interpretation of this
esquetology.
Does that make sense? Then you have
the Christian Zionist.
Okay. the Christian Zionist.
I'll explain who the Christian Zionists
are later on. Okay? But what the
Christian Zionist will do is they will
take this Jewish esquetology but
interpret it in a Christian context.
Okay. [snorts]
So for the Christians they believe that
yes all this will happen. Okay. The Jews
will establish their me age. But this is
really the antichrist system.
Okay. The antichrist who is a Jewish
messiah will establish a world
government that will dominate the world
and he will establish something called
the mark of the beast.
Mark of the beast is basically digital
ID. Okay. So just think of a microchip
in your forehead or wherever that
um and so you can be tracked you can be
monitor okay so basically an AI system
okay so this is what the me age of the
Jews will look like but it's the
antichrist system
and eventually what will happen is that
the people will rebel against Israel and
this will lead something called the war
of Gog and Magog
okay And when it seems as though Israel
is about to be defeated in the battle of
Ammeran, okay, what will happen is that
Jesus will return.
Jesus will return second coming and he
will take all the Christians to heaven.
It's called the rapture. And then he and
then um he will kill a third of the
Jews. A third will convert. And
um this will usher the messianic age.
Okay. So this is the Christian
interpretation.
It's called Christian Zionism. But as
you can see what's really important is
the Jews first achieve their esquetology
before the Christians can achieve
theirs. The Christians need to use the
Jew Jews as a tool to achieve the second
coming. Okay? Does that make sense?
Right. And what's really important is
for the Solomon's temple.
Solomon's temple is where
um the Alaxak mosque is right now. So in
other words, for this es esot to happen,
you will need to destroy the alexak
mosque which is the third holiest site
in the Islamic world. And you can
imagine how angry Muslims will be and
this might initiate the war of Gog and
Magog. Okay. Another important thing
about this esquetology that's really
important is you need the Jews to return
to Israel. And how do you get the Jews
to return to Israel? Anti-semitism.
Okay. So, not only do you have to
destroy the Alex, which is, you know,
not very nice, but you also have to uh
promote anti-semitism around the world
to force the Jews to return. That's
another part of this plan,
right? As you can see, this is not a
nice plan. It causes a lot of death,
cause a lot of suffering, lot cause a
lot of persecution. But both Jews and
Christians believe that for the meant
age to come, there has to be an age of
tribulation. There has to be the
Antichrist. There has to be the war of
Gog and Mog. Okay? There has to be a
garden, basically. All right. So is this
is it making sense? Okay, this is this
is the again the esquetology which is a
script which is a plan that these
societies must implement in order to
achieve heaven on earth. The last people
I want to talk about are the Freemasons.
Okay, the Freemasons
um believe that they are sorry the
Freemasons believe that they are of the
enlightenment.
Okay,
sorry. Freemasons they are and they
practice a new philosophy called theism.
What makes theism different is that it's
an enlightenment philosophy. So the idea
is that God did create the world, the
universe. That's why we are here. But
then God left and now because of free
will, free choice, we can do whatever we
we want. Okay? And our mission is
basically to achieve godhood through
science, through open debate, through
rational thinking.
And what are the signs of godhood? How
do we know that we've come become God?
When we're able to do three things.
Okay, the first thing is to warp
reality.
Okay, to to basically manipulate the
essence
of matter. And we've been able to do
that because of something called the
nuclear bomb.
Right? So they we've achieved that. So
in other words, when the nuclear bomb
was a Freemason project to achieve
godhood, but not only that, after we
after they achieved the nuclear bomb,
they had to use it to show that they are
God, right? Because as we discussed
before,
at the end of World War II, the
Americans were firebombing Japan. The
war was over. They didn't have to drop
the bomb, but they dropped the bomb on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki. Okay, that's
number one. Number two is
they need to kill a king to show that
they are god because the king is
divinity right
god gives birth to kings only gods can
kill a king and who do they kill JFK
again this is conspiracy theor theory
okay [snorts] the third thing which a
god does is create life
okay and this is something that they
haven't done
We're going to imagine what this is.
This is AI.
Okay. So, these are the three missions
of the Freemasons and they've achieved
the first two. They've warped reality by
creating a nuclear bomb. They've killed
a king JFK. Now, the third thing they
want to do is create life which is AI.
Okay. In fact, we can also guess what
where this AI will take place. Why?
Because let's look at a map.
Okay, let's look at a map.
This is the equator.
33° north
of the equator are four places. Okay.
Now, 33 degrees is very important in
Freemasonry. There are 33 degrees in
Scottish right Freemasonry. It's a very
sacred number. All right. So 33 degrees
north of the equator, you have four
places. The first place is Trinity Site,
New Mexico in America, which is where
they tested the atomic bomb. Okay, you
go over across the Pacific to Japan. 33
days north is Hiroshima Nakasaki.
All right.
33 degrees north in America is Dallas,
Texas where they killed JFK.
So the last mission of um Freemason or
Freemasons to achieve their vision for
the world
um is creating AI. Right now question is
where would they do it? And the answer
is 33° north of the equator. Right? And
where is that? Jerusalem.
So this is the endgame guys. The
Freemasons will create artificial
intelligence in Jerusalem and this will
become the world government.
Again, this is just conspiracy theory.
Don't believe this. This is just for
fun. Okay? But if it happens like this,
then that's interesting. Okay? But
that's but that is the grand plan to
create a world government in Jerusalem.
And what what's the center of this world
government? Solomon's temple
because the Freemasons believe that
their founder was the one who created
Solomon's temple. So by recreating
Solomon's temple, you close the circle.
Okay. So again, this is very
complicated. Um and I don't want to get
too many things wrong, but this is a
general gist of it. And so what and so
what we can see is that all roads lead
to Jerusalem. That is the case. Okay.
then this helps us understand certain
things about the world that otherwise
don't make any sense. All right, so
let's go over them.
The first thing that doesn't make any
sense is America's war on terror. Yes, I
understand that America was attacked on
9/11.
I understand that.
But why did that go attack Libya and
Iraq and all these other places that had
nothing to do with al Qaeda? Okay. And
the answer is they're trying to create
something called the Greater Israel
Project.
They're trying to have Israel
become Pax Judea, the grand power in the
Middle East, because that's important in
all secret societies. Israel must become
the dominant power in the Middle East.
Okay, so this helps us understand why
the ter war of terror happened the way
it did. That's number one. Number two is
right now
America is threatening to attack Iran.
Why would they do that? Because in order
for Pak Judeica to come into being, Iran
must be taken out of the equation. Iran
must be destroyed. Then if that were to
happen, there would be no challenger to
the power of Paka. Okay, does that make
sense, right? The third thing is
um Silicon Valley
and AI.
So right now you have AI chat GPT which
doesn't really do anything, okay? It
makes cool images
um on your computer and it helps you
cheat on in school. Okay, that's about
it. Doesn't really do anything else. And
if you don't go to school, then you're
like, why am I using chatbt? Okay, and
you're not going to pay a lot of money
for it. So AI, it's a dead end. But at
the same time, all around the world,
everyone's spending billions, trillions
of dollars on data centers, right? So,
everyone's putting money into
AI, but then you're like, well, how can
you make money off that?
If you think the answer is
um for you to use AI, well, it's hard to
make money off that. But if the answer
is to create an AI surveillance state,
that makes a lot more sense, right?
A surveillance state, very easy, guys.
We have it in China. Okay, it's digital
ID and digital currency
and the idea is that
everything you buy,
everything you do will be tracked and so
they can create a profile on you. This
profile
will tell the government who you are,
how you behave, what you think. Not only
that, the government can also manipulate
how you think, how you behave. Okay? And
this is of course called the mark of the
beast,
right?
And so that's what Pax decided is a
global AI surveillance system. Okay? It
also helps us explain
immigration
in Europe.
Okay? Because the war on terror, you've
sent these millions of refugees from
Libya, Syria, Afghanistan, Iraq into
Europe, which is causing a lot of
conflict in Europe. Why? Why would that
happen? Well, for Paka to come into
being, you need to destroy the world.
Okay?
So, I'm not saying this is true, but I'm
saying like if the goal is packed, it
does help us connect the dots. It helps
explain why things are happening the way
they are. Okay.
Also,
the last thing is anti-semitism. Okay.
So, you may have noticed on if you're
online, people don't like the Jews. And
this is like out of nowhere after after
October 7th. Um, you have anti-semitism
over the internet. Now, I have
criticized Israel before. Okay? But
anti-semitism is not the same thing as
anti-ionism, right? Zionism is a belief
that Israel is a chosen
uh people and the promised land and all
that. Okay? But Judaism as religion,
it's perfectly fine. So why would people
not care about the difference between
anti-inism, anti anti-semitism? Okay?
And you can argue it's all purposeful
because remember the part of the plan is
to force the Jews to return to Israel.
That's very important for this plan to
work out. Okay? It's it's key. That's
why you are seeing so much anti-semitism
around the world today.
Okay? And the last thing of course and
something we'll discuss is something
called the red heers. So red heers are
red cows that are perfectly genetically
modified and you need the red heers in
order to um you have to sacrifice the
red heers to purify the ground in order
to reconstruct the Solomon's temple.
Okay? And guess what? They've already
they've already sacrificed the red half
first. So it seems as though everything
is in place. All right? They're moving
towards Pax Judeica.
[snorts]
All right?
So let's discuss
what will happen in the short term and
in the long term if Paka really is the
end goal. Okay. So when you have Israel
fighting wars everywhere. Okay. The main
enemy right now is Iran.
In Europe, you have the Europeans about
to go to war with Russia.
In Ukraine,
America right now is threatening to
attack Venezuela. Okay, South America.
You have 10% of the
um US Navy in the Caribbean and they're
about to attack Venezuela.
You have China
and Japan
at conflict. You have India here and you
have Africa. Okay. So, so what's going
to happen in the short term? Okay. Well,
what we know is that Europe is planning
to go to war with Russia.
Okay.
Europe is about to go to war with
Russia. Okay.
At the same time, you have a lot of
immigrants in Europe and this is this is
going to create civil wars in Europe.
Okay. Civil war. So you have both war
with Russia as well as civil war. So
Europe is kind of screwed. Okay.
America has the same situation where the
left right divide is so polarized that
eventually they'll go to war. If you
read the news, you may have heard about
the uh shootings at Brown University as
well as this MIT physicists who were
shot. Okay, so random violence will be
more and more common in the United
States. And you can argue that's all
deliberate because the idea is is this.
Let's just say you have a jar. You put
red ants in the jar and black ants in a
in a jar. They get along fine. But you
take the jar and you just shake it up
and now they're at war with each other.
Okay, that's what's happening where the
left and right, they really don't like
each other. They don't talk to each
other and they refuse to engage uh in
debate with each other, but then they're
going to they're not going to fight each
other unless there's violence, in which
case their trouble mentality takes over
and they start killing each other. Okay?
So, we're going to expect civil war in
the United States.
Then you're going to have the Americans
start to attack Venezuela and possibly
other countries in South America. So,
America is in for a bad time. Okay.
China,
yeah, I mean, Japan and China and India,
they're all going to have conflicts with
each other. But also, what we should
expect is that America starts to embargo
China, meaning America uses its sea
power to block China from accessing
resources, more seas. And China imports
most of its oil
and a lot of its food. So if there's a
blockade of China, you can expect the
Chinese economy to really suffer. Okay.
All right. But and then what we can
expect to happen is America at some
point will go to war with Iran and this
will destroy both countries. Okay? Iran
will not lose this war, but it won't win
this war either because America is just
going to bomb the crap out of Iran. It's
going to send Iran back decades. But
America will lose this war. But this is
important because America loses war,
it's forced out of the Middle East. And
once it's forced out of the Middle East,
all its military assets goes to Israel,
which creates the Pax Judea. Does that
make sense, guys? That's the plan. Okay.
Now you have Pax Judea.
And what PUA will do is start to control
the world because through chaos and
conflict Pax Judea can make a lot of
money, right? Because Paka, what's going
to happen is that you have these
technology companies like Google,
they're going to move over to Pak Judea
and build a global surveillance state.
You have civil wars, you need AI to
control people. If you're going to war
with Russia, you need weapons, okay? But
you also need financing as well. So, you
can expect a lot of banks to move to
Israel and it's possible Israel becomes
now the global reserve currency because
everyone is trading with Israel.
If you're Russia, you need to trade with
you need to trade your resources, right?
Oil, energy, and grain. Okay? So, Russia
controls a third of the world's car
carbohydrates. Guess what, guys? Israel
controls Africa.
So, what will happen is that Russia and
other countries will sign a trade
agreement with Israel and Israel becomes
a center of global trade.
Okay, does that make sense? So this is
how tax Judeica will
um
profit and remember that Israel has the
world's best intelligence agency the
Mossad and what they can do is go go
around the world and create as much
chaos as possible. Okay. So while the
world is burning, Israel pes Jacob is
profiting
and that's what the future looks like
for the next 10, 20 years. And this will
of course lead to the rise of the
antichrist
who will take control of pack Judeica
and
force the world to eventually attack
Israel in something called the war of
Gog and this will of course lead to
second coming of Jesus. So, that's a
grand plan. Okay. Right.
Any questions?
Does it make sense to you guys? I know
it's evil and you know what? I could be
complete idiots. Okay. I I could just
make making all this up. But you have to
ask yourself three questions. Does it
connect the past? Does it explain what's
happened in the past? Does it explain
what's happening today?
And will these things happen in the
future? Okay. So, we we we haven't lived
with the future yet, but you can see the
trends.
Uh yeah. Yeah. Vincent.
Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Okay.
>> Like you said that AI like they will
like God create lives and create AI at
Jerusalem, but I think like CHBT they
already create AI in Silicon Valley.
[clears throat]
Okay. ChachiBT is not AI. Oh, it's an
LLM. Okay. Like artificial intelligence
is a thinking conscious sentient force.
That's like God. So they're trying to
create God in Jerusalem. Okay. Out of
Solomon's temple. Does that make sense?
Okay. Any more questions before we go to
the PPD?
But you guys understand what's
happening, right? Okay. Let's let's go
to PPD.
>> [snorts]
>> And again guys, it's all just
speculation on my part. Uh I have no
idea what will happen, okay? Like
everyone else.
Okay. All right guys, the promised land.
This is the greater Israel project.
Okay. This is what Yahweh promised to
Abraham in the Bible. As you as you as
you can see, it's pretty huge. This
entire Middle East extends from the Nile
to the Euphrates in
Iraq. Okay. It's a huge area and um if
you say the Israelites are sorry the the
is Israelis are want to achieve the
greater Israel project they call you
conspiracy theorist like we don't want
that. Okay but explain two things to me.
First of all why is the greater Israel
map on a chiron of an IDF soldier. Okay
these are soldiers Israeli soldiers and
they wear the insignia of the greater
Israel project. Okay this is the map.
Also, if you look at the flag of Israel,
there are two blue lines, right? These
represent rivers, the Nile and the
Euphrates.
All right? So, if it's a conspiracy
theory, then how do you explain these
two things? All right? But I want to
argue to you know what purea it's not
about Israel or the greater Israel
project. What it is ultimately is an
alliance of transnational capital,
multinationals like Google and Meta and
intelligence agencies that will be based
in Jerusalem. Okay? So, secret societies
will be based in Jerusalem and they will
use it as a headquarters for their
global conspiracy but um and they will
profit from chaos and conflict in around
the world because they think that this
is the culmination of their prophecy.
But it doesn't necessarily mean the Jews
will be in charge. Okay? Does that make
sense, guys? Okay. So, it's it's a much
more complicated idea than people think
it is.
All right. So, where do we get this
stupid idea from? Okay. It actually
starts with Isaac Newton. So, Isaac
Newton, you learn about him in physics
class. You learn that he's a founder of
calculus. You learn about Newtonian
mechanics. Okay. But actually, these are
just side projects of his. That was not
his what that that was not his focus. He
spent most of his most of his life
focusing on reading the Bible to
understand the grand plan of God. And he
wrote a book called observations upon
the prophecy of Daniel and the populace
of St. John. Okay, that's where his
focus was. And he believed he found the
Bible code and he was a member of secret
societies. He's he was a member of the
British elite. And if someone like Isaac
Newton is telling you like this is what
the Bible says and this guy who found a
calculus and who developed the three
laws of motion, you'll probably believe
him. Okay, but the guy was insane.
All right, so what he did was he's he's
looked at certain sections of the Bible
and put them together into a story about
Okay, and so this is Ezekiel 37.
[snorts] And so, um, Ezekiel 37 says
that the Lord God tells the prophet, uh,
Ezekiel that, yes, I've scattered the
people of Israel, but now I bring back
together, and then I will make your
nation great. I will make flowers bloom.
I will make your city prosperous. Okay?
And this is all in the Bible. Um,
Ezekiel 38 says that eventually there'll
be a war of Gog and Mog when Gog and
Magog will come invade Israel. But God
will come and defend Israel and he will
destroy Gog and Magog. And if you read
the Bible, we're not talking to read the
Bible, but it's really violent language.
So the Israelis believe that for heaven
to come, the first must be hell on
earth.
All right. So Newton's plan to force
second coming. Okay. And this becomes
the basis of Freemasonry, right?
Freemasons really were really invented
in order to promote the second planet
cupping plant. The Freemasons were first
uh in England but then where did they
go? They went to America. Many of the
founding fathers of America including
Benjamin Franklin, George Washington
were Freemasons. So America was founded
in many ways to achieve this plan. Okay.
So what's the plan? Well, you have to
first reconstitute the nation of Israel
and make it prosper. Okay. It's really
important that it becomes very wealthy.
And in fact, Israel is one of the
wealthiest countries in the world. Um,
you have to have the Jewish diaspora
return to Israel. That means you promote
prosperity, but you also have to promote
a Jewish conspiracy. So, while you're
letting the Jews get rich in the West,
you're also promoting the idea that the
Jews control the world. Okay? It's all
part of this plan.
Um, you have to have rebuild someone's
temple. You have to have the war of Gog
and Magog. You have to have the
antichrist. You have you have to immer.
Okay? And this will force Jesus to
return and usher in the millennium age.
Okay, does that make sense? That's a
grand plan.
And unfortunately, most of these things
have been achieved. Okay, these are the
Freemasons and and the top leadership is
focused on achieving this plan developed
by Newton. Eventually what will happen
is that um Adam Weisshob will found the
Illuminati with Jacob Frank and they
will infiltrate Freemasons. And why do
the Freemasons allow
Adam Weisshob and the Illuminati to
infiltrate the Freemasons? Because Jews
are an important part of this plan. They
need Jews in place. They need Jews to go
back to Jerusalem and build the nation
of Israel and conquer the world in order
for this plan to work out. Okay. So it
is a alliance between the Freemasons and
the Illuminati.
Um this is Rothschild and Rothschild
will establish many f many branches
throughout Europe. Okay. Jacob Frank
we've discussed in the past but this is
a major alliance. Okay. All right. Once
we understand that secret societies and
their grand planet in in motion now it
helps us understand why things turn out
the way they did. For example, now we
understand where British philosophy
comes from. We discussed last class
about John Lock, David Hume, Bentham,
Mill, Marx, Darwin. Okay, these were all
sp thinkers sponsored by Britain to
propo to propose to promote a certain
understanding of the world that is
materialistic and which will build
foundation for the second coming. Okay.
So, John Lock said private property is
what's important. David Hume philosophy
is pointless. Don't think about God.
just focus on material wealth. Um Jeremy
Bentham utility is everything. Okay. How
do we know what's good what's right if
it if it benefits someone? Okay. Uh John
Mill liberty of the individual is
everything. So making sure that people
are individually happy as opposed to
being spiritual. Uh car marks freedom of
individual from material want. Charles
Darwin man is a monkey. Okay. So this is
promoting a certain worldview that will
help promote the com the second coming.
All right.
So look, if you just look at science,
there are certain things they study and
certain things they don't study. For
example, they spend a lot of time
studying particle physics. Who cares?
Can I ask you this question? Who cares
about particle physics? They spend
billions, trillions of dollars on this
stupid thing. They built something
called the CERN particle collider to
figure out what the underlying
atom is. Okay. Is it really important?
Isn't solving world prop poverty more
important? I I don't know. You can take
all that money you spend on stupid
collider. Make sure everyone in the
world has enough to eat. They don't want
to do that though. All right. You also
have focus on outer space AI. Okay. So
the very direction of science, it's very
very specific. Okay. They're trying to
achieve a materialist understanding of
the world. And also, if you try to uh
this is the collider, okay, I again, I
don't understand why they're spending
trillions of dollars on the stupid
thing. This is the current collider uh
LXC
uh [snorts] in Switzerland and now
they're going to be build a bigger one.
Here's how big it is, right? What are
they trying to do here?
Are they really trying to figure out
particle physics?
Maybe, maybe not. All right. All right,
guys. Jacob Frank.
What Jacob Frank tells us is
um there are different dimensions.
Okay. And another dimension is big
brother who's a friend of his but he's
stuck in his dimension. He's trying to
come into our dimension but he needs our
help. So what's certain particle
accelerator trying to do right? Is it
really trying to discover particle
physics or is it really trying to break
the dimensions like they did with the
nuclear bomb? Okay, do you understand
the people believe the nuclear bomb it
was really about creating an
interdimensional portal for brick
brother to come into and now people are
saying is it possible the cern particle
accelerator is trying to bring in these
um interdimensional demons to our world
to conquer us to enslave us that would
make a lot more sense in particle
physics okay guys
all right what does science not study
okay it doesn't study consciousness
which is a number one problem in the
world, right? Wouldn't it be nice to
know how we think? Okay. [laughter]
Would it be nice to know how I come up
with the ideas I do in class and teach
it to you and how you respond to my
ideas? We have a much more basic problem
in particle physics. We don't do that
guys. Okay? There's abely no money or
very limited funding in the study of
consciousness, imagination, intuition,
anything in material spirit. Okay? Like
ghosts or spirits, we don't study at
all.
um religious truth. We don't also don't
study kindness, happiness and love.
Okay? We don't study what is the basis
of these things. We don't care. We don't
study telepathy connection. We don't
study intelligence of animals and
plants. We also don't study ancient
architecture and civilizations. So if
you if you go to these ancient sites
like goep,
we discussed goep before. We only have
have uncovered 5% of it. Okay? We don't
care what is underneath copetepe
because it's possible that if we were to
discover everything we would then it
would refute traditional paradigms of
the world including evolution.
All right. So science is focused on
spreading one particular paradigm about
the world and discounting every
everything else.
Right? So why is that? Okay. Another
thing that's really interesting about
science is it hasn't really improved in
the past 50 70 years. We're spending
billions, $200 on science, but we
haven't really improved science that
much. There have been no great
discoveries and there are three three
reasons why. Okay, the first is
specialization. You're only focus you're
only allowed to focus on one very
specific problem and without generalist
without without being able to think of
science very broadly, it's hard to come
up with new discoveries.
All right. The other thing is you have a
very strict bureaucracy. So as a
scientist, you spend most of your time
actually applying for funding. You
actually don't spend most of your time
trying to solve the promise pro problems
of the universe. The third thing is
credentialism where if you don't have a
certain PhD and you don't belong to a
major research university, you're not
allowed to talk about science. Okay. So
because of these three reasons, it's
hard to do science. It's hard to
discover truth. And that's the
intention. The intention is to prevent
people from discovering the truth of the
world. Okay? Now, science is not very
good at creating new things, but it's
very good at faking things. Okay? It's
very good at faking things. Also, guys,
it's possible we might they might fake
something else called an alien invasion.
S is very good at that. It's not good at
creating spaceships, but it's good at
faking spaceships. Okay? There's a
difference.
All right. So this is um Thomas and
he wrote something called the structure
of scientific revolutions and he just
says it's natural for paradigms new
ideas to it takes a very long time for
paradigms to take shape. But then then
if that's the case, how do you how do
you explain Einstein? The moment he
proposed relativity, boom, he's famous.
World famous. Okay. How do you how do
you explain Darwin? The moment he
proposed evolution, boom, he's world
famous. It's really strange like this
way. Okay. [snorts] And so one
explanation is secret societies control
the world. They have a certain
esquetology and they are promoting
things that push their esquetology
forward. That's how the world works.
Okay. So you think Okay. All right.
Um we also discussed last class the idea
of kinsspeak written by this uh uh Jew
in Britain who becomes the first Jewish
prime minister Benjamini and it's about
how Jews control the world and we were
like why is this happening and I I said
because it's part of the plan because
not only will not only are Jews supposed
to prosper in the west but they're all
supposed people are supposed to think
that they are part of the grand
conspiracy. Okay. Because the end goal
is anti-semitism and force them to
return to Israel. Okay.
[snorts]
All right. So with this plan in motion,
obviously the secret societies cannot
themselves come out and propose this
plan. The secret societies. Okay. So
they have different individuals do this
for them. This is Theo Herszel who who's
considered the founder of Zionism. The
idea of Zionism is that Jews deserve
their own homeland, preferably in
Palestine, okay, current day uh Israel.
And he wrote a book called the state of
for the Jews, okay? And it was heavily
promoted in 1896.
[snorts]
You also have something called the
Scoffield Bible, okay? Which is to take
Newton's plan and turn it and and and
then explain how the Bible and the plan
work together. Okay? And this is this
this is called um premillennial
dispensationalism. Okay? Don't don't
don't don't worry about the about the
idea. Okay?
Okay. All right. So um 1917 you have um
Lord Rothschild.
Okay. Balffor the British government is
sending a letter to Lord Rothchild
saying I have the pleasure of allowing
you to create a homeland for the Jews.
Okay. So again this part of the plan
where the British want to create Israel
but they're blaming the Jews for it.
Okay. They're saying it's the Jews who
want to create Israel.
Okay. So in 1948 they create the nation
of Israel.
Okay. This is the Herszel and remember
okay the nation of Israel it is not part
of this grand plan. It's it's what the
Jews aspire to. It is what the Jews
want. It's all initiated by the Jews.
Okay. This is very important.
Okay. Um
now one thing that they say one one
thing that the Israelites say is that um
we deserve Palestine because this is
what God promised to us in the Bible. We
are descendants of the Israelites. We
are Hebrew. We're all one blood. Now the
great thing about Jews, okay, and this
is why I have tremendous respect for
Jews is these Jewish intellectuals, they
are first and foremost committed to the
truth. So this is author Kesler, okay,
who is a Jewish intellectual and he
wrote something called the 13th tribe.
In this book, what he tells us is this
is nonsense, okay? The Jews,
most of them don't come from Israel.
They don't come from the Middle East.
They come from Ukraine.
Okay. And this is called the 13th tribe.
And he explains how what happened. Okay.
So, uh, Ember, could you, uh, read,
please?
>> Yes.
>> All right. Could you, um, read this
patch? Okay.
>> Okay.
>> At the beginning of the 8th century, the
world was polarized between the two
super powers representing Christianity
and Islam.
>> So, these two powers are the Bison
Empire as well as the Abbas Caliphate.
Okay. Their ideological doctrines were
welded to power politics [clears throat]
pursued by the classical methods of
propaganda, subversion, and military
conquest. The Khazar Empire represented
a third force, which had proved equal to
either of them, both as an adversary and
an ally. But it could only maintain its
independence by accepting neither
Christianity nor Islam. for either
choice would have automatically
subordinated it to the authority of the
Roman emperor of the cal califf of
Baghdad.
>> Okay. So do you understand this idea?
It's very simple. You have these three
powers in Eurasia. You have the
Bisantines and you have the absence.
Okay. Bisantines are Christian. The
Abisites are Muslim and these are the
two dominant religions. And the Khazars
think they're a power and if they
convert to right now they're pagan. If
they convert to Christianity, they now
have to obey Bentine. They obey If they
convert to Islam, they now have to obey
the uh opposites. They don't do either.
Okay? So, so they pick another religion
which is Judaism, right? And it makes
sense because Judaism is the first
religion. It is from Judaism in which
you have Islam as well as Christianity.
And therefore, Judaism is superior. And
therefore, we as ours are superior.
Okay? So, this makes perfect sense,
right? Keep on going.
>> There had been no lack of efforts by
either court to convert Khazars to
Christianity or Islam, but all they
resulted in was the exchange of
diplomatic courtesies, dynamic inter
marriages, and shifting military
alliances based on mutual self-interest.
Relying on its military strength, the
Khazar Kingdom with its hinterland of
vassal tribes was determined to preserve
its position as the third force leader
of the uncommitted nations of the step
steps.
>> So the Kasar Empire is very ambitious as
well. Okay, it sees itself as a great
power eventually wants to unite the
different tribes of step nations and
conquer the world. But to do that, it
needs it needs its own distinct
identity. So it's not going to convert
to Christianity or Islam. All right,
keep on going.
>> At the same time, their intimate contact
with the Byzant uh Byzantium and the
Caliphate had taught the Khazars at
their primitive shamanism was not only
barbaric and outdated compared to the
great monotheistic creeds, but also
unable to confer on the leaderships the
spiritual and legal authority which the
rulers of the two theocratic world
powers, the califf and the emperor,
enjoyed. Yet the conversion to either
creed would have meant submission, the
end of independence, and thus would have
defeated its purpose. What could have
been more logical than to embrace a
third creed which was uncommitted
towards either of the two yet
represented of the venerable foundation
of both?
>> Yeah. Okay. This is a very simple idea.
Monotheism is very important because
they give one god gives ultimate
authority to one person which allows for
for the creation of empire, right?
Otherwise every god is equal and you
have like a lot of gods. So it's
important to have one god. You have
three religions that celebrate one god.
You have Islam which is doing very well.
You have Christianity which is doing
really well. You have Judaism and no
one's [clears throat] practicing
Judaism. So let's just take it for
ourselves. Really simple. Okay. So this
was a mass conversion of an entire
people to Judaism. Okay. Does that make
sense?
All right. And so this this what the map
looks like. As you can see it's huge
area. This is Ukraine, okay? Modern day
Ukraine, the Ka Empire. Then you have
you have the uh Bisantines and you have
the Abbassids. And the Khazars saw
themselves as equal to both. They want
to maintain a separate identity. Okay.
They don't want to be consumed by either
empire. [snorts]
Okay. And this is another map that shows
uh Kazer Kazeria. Okay. And then Yep.
[clears throat]
All right. Can you hear my reading? Um,
uh, the only mercy,
>> the only mercy shown by history to those
who took to flight or were driven to it
was the existence of Kazeria both before
and after the conversion.
>> Okay, so it doesn't make sense. So Jews
are being persecuted in Europe all the
time. They have no place to go except
Kazeria, which is now the Jewish
homeland. And the Jews know about about
Kazeria because they're traders. They're
merchants. They're part of the diaspora.
So information is spreading about uh
Kazeria and they all go there and these
Jews are heavily intellectual and they
so so they bring their cultural
practices to Kazeria. Also we discussed
this before what is a Jewish person? A a
Jewish person is not someone who is born
Jewish. A Jewish person is someone who
reads the Bible and accepts a cultural
practice of the Jews. And therefore it's
really easy to become a Jew. Keep on
going. Before it was a refugee haven,
after it became a kind of national home,
the refugees were products of a superior
culture and were no doubt an important
factor in creating that cosmopolitan
tolerant outlook which so impressed the
Arab uh chronicers quoted before their
influence and no doubt their prolet
>> prostitizing
>> proilizing zeal. This was an age when
conver converting unbelievers by force
or perse uh persuasion was a foremost
concern that the Jews too indulged in it
is shown by the fact that since the rule
of justine and Bzantine law threatened
severe punishments for the attempt to
convert Christians to Judaism while for
Jews molesting converts to Christianity
the penalty was death by fire. Sharf uh
P25 would have made itself felt first
and foremost at the court and among
leading no uh notables. They may have
combined in their missionary efforts
theological arguments and messenic
prophecies with a shrewd assignment of
the political advantages that the
Khazars would derive from adopting a
neutral religion. The exiles also
brought with them Bisantine arts and
crafts, superior methods in agriculture
and trade, and the square Hebrew
alphabet. Okay. So, not only did the
Khazars wanted their own religion that
was distinct from Bisines and the
Abbassad, but they also wanted um the
skills, the knowledge, the culture, the
science, the medicine that the Jews
would bring with them. Okay? So, this
marriage made perfect sense. Okay? So,
from logical perspective,
this makes complete sense.
Unfortunately, you're not allowed to
discuss this. Okay? because this is
embarrassing for the nation of Israel.
You're not they're not saying this is
this is not what happened because
there's all evidence to suggest this is
what happened. They're saying you're not
allowed to discuss this. Okay.
All right. Can you keep on reading?
That's u ethnically the tribes
>> ethically the cemetic tribes on the
waters.
>> Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. So, so okay.
So, Kazeria is around for a long time, a
few centuries, but then eventually get
they become conquered up by the Mongols.
The Mongols are ferocious. They're
killing a lot of people. So these
Kazarians have no choice but to
immigrate over to East Asia. Sorry, to
Eastern Europe. Okay. And then and they
become the European Jews.
All right. And so what Kesler is going
to do is he's going to show evidence to
suggest that they all came from one
place. All these different European
European Jews, they have similar
cultural practices, which means they
originate from a similar place. Okay,
keep on going. Ethnically,
>> ethnically, the the Seemetic
[clears throat] tribes on the waters of
the Jordan and the Turko Khazar tribes
on the Vulga were of course miles apart.
But they had at least two important
formative factors in common. Each lived
at a focal junction where the great
trade routes connecting east and west,
north and south intersect. A
circumstance which predisposed them to
become nations of traders of
enterprising travelers or ruthless
cosmopolitans. as hostile propaganda has
unactionately labeled them. But at the
same time, their exclusive religion
fostered a tendency to keep themselves
and stick together
uh to establish their own communities
with their own places of worship,
schools, residential quarters, and
ghettos originally self-imposed in
whatever town or country they settled.
This rare combination of wonderlust and
ghetto mentality reinforced by me uh me
misanic hopes and chosen race pride both
ancient Israelites and medieval Khazars
shared even though the latter trace
their descendant not to Shem but to
Jaffeth.
>> So genetically speaking the um Kazerians
and the Israelites have nothing in
common. Okay, but they seriously culture
and that's who who we ultimately are.
were products of culture as opposed to
genes. Okay. Um these are um uh kerites
in the Korean the they the uh in
basically Ukraine. Okay. And as you can
see they're Jews
um and they practice the quazarian
version of Judaism. Okay. Um the first
impression, okay,
>> the first impression one gains is a
striking similarity between certain
privileges uh privileged positions held
by Kazar Jews in Hungary and in Poland
in those early days. Both the Hungarian
and Polish sources referred to Jews
employed as mint
>> mint masters
>> mint masters administrators of the royal
revenue uh controllers of the salt
monopoly tax colle uh collectors and
money lenders i.e. bankers. This
parallel suggests a common origin of
those two immigrant communities. And as
we can trace the origins of the bulk of
Hungarian jewelry to the magarazar
nexus, the conclusion seems
self-evident.
>> Okay. All right. Thank you. Thank you.
All right. So, does this make sense?
Okay. There's a lot of evidence to
suggest like the uh Khazars were Jews.
And this is important to understand
because guess what? the the Khazar Jews,
they will take over Europe. Okay? And
you have three different types of Jews.
Uh you have the Sepharic Jews, which
which basically the Jews who were
expelled from Spain. Okay? These are
real Jews. You have the Mazari Jew,
Mazari Jew, Jews who were in the um
Islamic world. Again, these are real
Jews. The blue, these Askite Jews,
they're not real Jews. They're
converted. Okay? This something you're
not you're not to discuss at all. even
though the evidence is so stark. The the
other issue with the Ashkenazi is that
um they make up 80% of all Jews in the
world today. Okay. And so you go to
issue and they says like we we're here
because this is what God promised to us.
That's nonsense. But again, you're not
to discuss this even though again the
evidence is stark. All right. All right.
So um this conspiracy also helps us
again explain the JFK assassination.
Okay. As well as
uh so this is the book King Kill. Um you
can read it online for yourself. It's by
Down and Hoffman. It goes into why the
Freemasons would want to kill JFK. The
sort of ritual sacrifice ideas behind
behind it. Okay. [snorts]
Um 911. All right. Why did 911 happen?
because it's all part of this grand
plan. Now that happened because America
needed to go to Middle East and destroy
the Middle East to create Pax Judea and
that's exactly what they did again al
Qaeda is yes I understand al Qaeda did
911 but then why did you have to go ball
destroy Libya uh why do you have to go
destroy Afghanistan and Iraq and Syria?
Okay. So, uh and the last place that
they need to destroy is Iran in order to
achieve the pack Judeaic Cup project.
Okay. Um ISIS guys, ISIS is,
you know, these fanatical Muslims and
they hate Israel, but they never
attacked Israel. Okay? They've never
ever in their history attacked Israel.
That's why they're probably controlled
by the Mossiah. Okay? Okay. And these
guys go around and destroy the entire
Middle East, but they never attacked
Israel. Okay. Really strange how this
happens.
Okay. And the and all this war on the
terror, what it does is it creates all
these millions of migrants to Europe,
which is destabilizing European society.
[snorts]
And these societies, look, Libya was
once a middle class, prosperous society.
And now you have these slave markets.
You got these millions of Africans who
are sold as slaves in Libya. It is an
anarchy now.
Okay. So 2015 you have all these
immigrants going to Europe and the
Europeans like we don't want these
immigrants because what are we going to
do with these immigrants? They're poor.
We don't have the money. We don't have
the system in order to accommodate these
immigrants. And Angela Merkel, who is
the leader of Europe at this time, the
German chancery, she says, "We can do
this, guys. We can do this." And it was
a it's it's it has become a
dumpster fire. Okay?
And like guys, in 2015, everyone knew
this was going to happen. Everyone knew
that you brought in millions of
immigrants who did not speak English,
who did not share European cultural
values, and who didn't have much
education.
Um, this this would happen. Okay.
Europeans are not as open as the
Americans are. Okay? And even these
immigrants are causing problems in
America, right? And and at no point did
the Europeans say, "Screw you, America.
You did this to us." At no point,
okay?
And and and you can argue like, okay,
maybe it's bureaucratic incompetence,
but at the same time, it's all it could
also be part of the grand plan. to
create Jack Pria. This is October 7th uh
when Hamas went and killed a lot of
Israel's um Israelis and this of course
led to what's happening in Gaza today.
Okay. And what's happening in Gaza today
led to all these protests for Palestine
around the world and a surge in
anti-semitism.
And the surge in anti anti-semitism
ultimately lead to killings around the
world. So this is Bondi Beach in Sydney,
Australia, where you have, if you read
the news, um, two Islamic State uh,
supporters killed 15 Jews celebrating a
Jewish festival in Bonnie Beach. And
quite honestly, um, we can expect more
of the more of this to happen in the
future. And you can say this is all just
an accident or you can say well you know
it's part of the plan guys. Okay these
are the red hers
and these red heers were spent people
spent millions of dollars to generally
create perfect red heers because nature
doesn't produce perfect red heers and uh
uh what people say the rumor is that
these red heers have been sacrificed
already. So now they're getting ready to
rebuild Solomon's temple which will be
the site of the world government. Okay.
Back to Judeica.
Um let's go to Silicon Valley. Okay.
Bill Gates, Mark Zuckerberg,
Jeff Bezos, Elmas. How do how they
become billionaires? Guys, I don't think
they're smarter than us. In fact, I
don't I don't think they're that smart.
Okay, Steve Jobs is a smart guy. I I I
will say Steve Jobs is a really smart
guy, but these other guys are pretty
normal guys. How do they become
billionaires?
All right. So, Silicon Valley people say
that some Silicon Valley is a hot bed of
innovation. That is complete and utter
nonsense. The hot bed of innovation is
the American military because they spent
billions of dollars on innovation. Okay?
So, these are computers that develop for
war purposes. Okay? for the nuclear bomb
to fight World War II to fight the Cold
War. They spent billions of dollars to
develop this technology and then what
happened was this technology became
smaller and smaller and so much smaller
that Steve Wnak was able to take this
technology and create our own personal
computer. Now this is kind of strange
because this R&D was funded by the
American government. How did this one
guy Steve Wnak how was able to take all
this knowledge and then go and make his
own computer? What what what did the
American military led him? In fact,
what's really strange is that while
Steve Losak was building his own
computer, which will become the Apple
computer, he was working for Huard
Packard. In other words, everything he
did should have been the IP of Huard
Packard. And in fact, Steve Warak said
to his boss, listen, you guys pay me,
you guys train me, if you want this PC
that I'm going to create, I'm I'm happy
to give it to you. And Hilo Pako said to
him, "No, keep it for yourself."
That's really strange, guys. What
corporation is so generous? Why would
they do that? Well,
there are three good reasons. Okay, the
first reason is that if the American
military were to promote personal
computers, every American in the world
would say, "Screw you." Okay, you guys
are in the military. You guys are
responsible for the Vietnam War. You
guys are responsible for militive deaths
around the world. Why would I take a
computer from you knowing that it's from
the military? You're you're going to use
a computer to spy on me, man. You're
going to use this computer to turn me
into a robot. There's no I'm I'm touch
this computer. But it's coming from
Steve Jobs. That's different, right? Oh,
Steve Jobs. He's a visionary. He's
messianic.
Of course, I'll buy this personal
computer from Steve Jobs. Okay. Um
second is at this time in history,
America's at war with Soviet Union.
Okay. Which system is better?
communism or capitalism. And so you
wanted So if you said that, okay, we're
the government and we spent billions of
dollars to build this technology that
proves you communism is better, right?
But if it's like, no, no, no, it's these
guys working by themselves in Silic
Silicon Valley in the garage. They got
all these ideas for themselves that
proves capitalism is better. Okay, that
proves entrepreneurship is better. Now
the last reason and this is most
important is
if the US government built this
knowledge right it belongs to American
people.
So, how do you monetize public knowledge
when you create private companies
controlled by secret societies? That
makes perfect sense, right? And we can
now understand all these guys, Bill
Gates, [snorts] Alam Mas, they're front
people. They're just poster boys.
They're not they're not wheeling
command. It's societies that's really in
control. Okay.
Sorry.
All right. Um, another example is
Google. So the American military spent
billions of dollars, trillions of
dollars of taxpayer money to build this
fiber optic network which is the base of
the of the internet. Okay? With this
fiber optic network, you couldn't have
the internet.
And then
these two guys in their 20s took over
this network and create Google. It's the
same thing as you know the government
spends billions of dollars building a
highway. Okay? And then you come along
and says I'm going to build a toll
booth. Same thing. Why were they allowed
to do that? But not only that, but now
they're slowly building their own
underwater
um fiber optic network. So b they're
basically privatizing this network
created by the American military. Yes, I
understand they're spending their own
money to build this uh network, but it's
American military that spent taxpayer
taxpayer money to build to do the R&D
for all this. Okay, that's where the
real value is.
Mark Zuckerberg guys look look he's not
that smart okay and look the other thing
is he was 19 years old he stole this
idea from his Harvard classmates and
then he got billions of dollars from
venture capitalist to fa to start
Facebook where did he get this money
Facebook is not a great idea right
social media great but I mean like I
could also start a social media company
you could start a social media company
the other thing is like Yahoo at one
point offered this guy a billion dollars
to buy Facebook, we'll give you a
billion dollars. That's a lot of money,
right? You would have taken I would have
taken in but but market like nah, I
would know. I wouldn't know what to do
with the money. That's Why did
you start Facebook in the first place?
But to make money, okay, so you have
these three questions. First of all, why
are these people giving him money? He's
a he's a 19-y old guy. He's a Harvard
dropout. That's all he is. No
experience, nothing. Second question is
if you're someone who's that young he
gets and you succeed so much you would
suffer from hubris from ego you make a
lot of mistakes right the guy has never
failed in his life the third thing of
course is I don't I understand why
Amazon Google and Apple are successful
okay go Apple has Steve Jobs Google
controls the world search Amazon
controls
um buying things right what does
Facebook do doesn't do thing,
right? So, how can we explain why Mark
Zuckerberg is so successful? Well,
there's actually an explanation.
This guys, okay, it's all part of a it's
possible. Okay, I'm not saying it is
true, but it's all part of the grand
conspiracy to create an AI civilian
state, which is which is what taxa is.
>> This guy. Okay,
>> they look the same. They look exactly
the same. They are the same. They look
like clones of each other. No
personality, no ideas of their own.
They're just robots. How do they become
so successful?
Right? And a guess what guys? Makes no
money, but at the same time, they get
trillions of dollars from investors to
build
data centers.
Okay? And these data centers allow you
to make really nice pictures and videos
online that do nothing. Okay, why are
all why is all this money being spent
except one day to
create a surveillance state? Okay,
that's what makes sense. The idea that
these things exist so that you can play
on the computer makes no sense. But
these things exist in order to one day
have complete control over what you do,
what you think, and how you behave. That
makes sense now. Okay.
Pax Judea.
All right. Alan Musk. Okay. I Yeah, I
understand millions of people worship
this guy. I don't know how this guy
makes money. Okay, if you look at Tesla
and Facebook and you came in and says,
"Listen, there's these two companies,
Facebook and Tesla, would you invest in
them?" If I and I be like, "No,
Facebook, there's no business model
here. I don't understand why people need
social media." And I don't understand
how Mark Zuckerberg, how he's he's going
to make money in the future. Alan Musk,
he gets all his money from government
subsidies. Tesla doesn't make any money,
man. And the guy's a
Okay. But
neural link. Okay. Why is he proposing
neural link? It's part of transhumanism,
right?
All right. So, Jacob Frank, guys. All
right. All everything goes back to Jacob
Frank. What does Jacob Frank believe? He
believes that what matters is at the end
of the world is the spirit becomes
flesh. You understand? The spirit
becomes flesh. What matters is not the
mind. What matters is matter. Second
thing he says is listen your laws tell
me to fast to suffer. I don't want that
crap. I want to enjoy my life. Okay. And
the third thing is this world cannot
have been created by God. It was created
by Satan because why would God allow us
to die? Therefore, we must defy Satan by
living forever. Okay. Now, if you
understand Frank, we understand the idea
of transhumanism.
Okay. This is a guy with his own bionic
eye that records things. This is a guy
with his own arm. This is a new trend in
the future. What is transhumanism?
The capacity to live forever. Okay. All
right. So, this is the future that we're
looking at. If you're a rich person, if
you're a powerful person, this this is
what you will experience. You will
experience
longevity, health, and beauty. Okay?
You will have organ transplants that
keep you young. You will have stem cell
therapy to repair any cancer, any
diseases. You have gene therapy. You
have blood transfusion. You have you
have replacement bodies. Okay? You will
be 20 years old forever. You have great
sex. You live forever. Okay? This is if
you are a billionaire. Everyone else,
uhoh.
Uhoh. Well, first of all, you become a
cyborg where you are now specialized for
certain function. Okay? They're going to
put microchips in your body so you you
can become a better accountant. Okay?
They'll they'll turn your arms into
cyborg bionic arms so you can be better
construction worker. Who knows? Okay.
Microchips inside of you, the mark of
the beast. What these microchips do?
They are digital ID and digital
currency. And guess what, guys? If
you're not happy, they'll know about it
and they'll give you drugs to make you
happy. If you you think this won't
happen, they've already have everything
in place. Okay? Addictive drugs to
control mood. Oh, and like if you're
lonely, don't worry, man. That's what AI
is for. You have an AI girlfriend and
boyfriend. And you know what? Most
people would prefer an AI boyfriend and
girlfriend. Okay?
Okay. And then it'll be an individual
matrix where you live in your own world.
So think of World of Warcraft, but in
the real world, okay? where everyone
who's your friend, your entire family,
it's all just AI generated.
>> Okay, you live in a perfect world.
>> Oh my god.
Okay, guys. Now, let's look at how Pax
profits what how they control the world.
Well, AI surveillance systems and AI
data centers will become a leader in
that. Okay? Because for ADA a data
centers to be effective, they need to be
safe. Everywhere else there's there's
going to be wars, right? Not Israel
because Israel has nuclear weapons. So
all the major technology companies will
be based in Israel in the future. Uh
weaponry, security, private militias to
protect you if you're at war. Boweapons
and bow warfare, psychological and
information warfare. Israel is really
good good at that. Intelligence
espionage and sabotage. Mosad is the
world's best intelligence agency.
Financing. Okay. So if you want to go to
war, you'll be financed by the Israelis.
trade access, transhumanism for the
global elite. Okay. This is how in the
future they will control the world. Does
that make sense?
All right. But we don't know how much of
the world will last because something
called the manic pole excursion. And
this will usher in something called the
mini ice age. Okay. So maybe God is not
happy with Pax Judeeka. Maybe we know no
one can defeat Pax Judica except God
himself. And maybe maybe God will
intervene but not in the way that it
says in the Bible. Okay, we don't know.
This is all speculation. Believe
whatever you want. Okay. So, um
any questions? Does it make sense to you
guys? Pax Judea, welcome to the future.
Okay. All right.
Let me go over some um Substack. So, um
I want to thank the founding members of
my Substack because they're extremely
generous and they've left some questions
and comments and so I will answer them
now. Okay. So, um could you help me uh
Amber by by reading the the questions?
>> Okay.
>> So, so I I I can rest a bit.
>> Okay. Dear Professor Tang, I'm an avid
viewer of all your lectures on YouTube
and your content on Substack and I want
to say a huge thank you for the
incredibly important content you are
sharing with the uh with humanity. I'm a
27-year-old Jew living in Israel. I
oppose any Zionist idea and any nation
state whatsoever, including Israel and
uh including Palestine. I would like to
know whether you think it is advisable
for the younger generation of Jews, both
those living in Israel and those who do
not to live in Israel. On the one hand,
anti-semitism is likely to increase the
despora uh yeah despora which will
diaspora which will lead many Jews to
think that Israel is the safest place
for us and the chain of events that are
likely to unfold will cause Jews to
believe that the Messiah is just around
the corner. On the other hand, we are
heading towards living here in a tech uh
technocratic ghetto of surveillance,
digital ID systems and so on. I'm sure
that many sane Jews who simply want to
live in peace regardless of religion or
race follow you your wonderful work and
would like to know what you think is the
right course of action for us. I don't
know whether this question is priority
for you to address in a video and it's
uh completely understandable if you
choose not to share it, but even a
written response from you would be more
than enough. Thank you very much. Okay.
So, thank you uh Daniel for your
comment. Um, listen, I think I Pastor is
not about the Jews. It's about the these
evil people who want to control the
world and they want to use Jews and
Israel as a tool to do so. And a lot of
Jews recognize this fact. A lot of Jews
recognize that traditionally they've
been used by empires in the past. And
this is a great question. And I'll say
certain I'll say certain things. The
first thing is that I believe that the
people who are most who will be most
resistant to pastor the people who stand
up and fight pasture will actually be
Jews themselves. Jews have have a great
tradition of being on the front lines of
resistance for justice for humanity for
all that is good in the world. So I
believe that Jews will play a very
important part in the resistance against
uh past Judea.
Second thing that I will say is that um
it things look dark but what we what
we've learned this semester are three
things. Okay. The first is that evil
must triumph so that good may rise.
There must be total darkness for the
light to shine and all hope must end so
that we can become hope ourselves. Okay.
So please remember there's divine spark
in us. When all hope seems lost, that
spark will remind you of who you are and
it will lead you into the light. Okay?
So, I don't have specific instructions
or ideas on how to counter purea,
but I think that being aware of paxa and
being aware that we individually have
the capacity to resist is fundamental to
what is to come. Okay. So, thanks to
Daniel for the question. Okay. All
right. Uh, this is from Kevin Joel. Can
you meet Amber?
>> Okay. I first want to thank whatever
gave you the courage to continue past
tribulations. Maybe Mrs. Young and
continuing to teach. Your will and
dedication to learning and teaching is
monumental compared to the attention
spans of newer generations. I think I
speak for most of us who watch, but you
have definitely made a historical impact
on us. It seems transnational
capitalism, franosism, has weaved its
web for hundreds of years, turning into
the monster it is today. What are
humanity's possible counters? Do you
think it it is religion? Will we ever
make a cyclic turn away from capitalism?
How long would it take to undo this
movement? Thank you. Never spot.
>> Okay, so you're absolutely right. Okay,
so thank again, thank you for this
question. Okay, the Frankus has spent ye
centuries preparing for today and that's
why they win because they're willing to
think long term. They're willing to work
together. They're willing to make
necessary sacrifices to achieve heaven
on earth in their eyes. Okay? And so we
need to if you want to defeat them, you
need to become like that. Okay? You need
to think long term. You need you need to
like understand you need to make
sacrifices. Okay? It's it's it's
something that you cannot defeat in one
day or 10 years or 100 years. It you
have to like believe in yourself. You
have to believe in humanity. You have to
respond by working hard by making
sacrifices. Okay? By learning. All
right? So that's the only way forward.
Also what we also know is that when
empires come into being, that's when
they end. Okay? So the moment priakica
comes into being, it has to end because
patcha becomes arrogant. It becomes
obvious. It becomes um narrow-minded. It
becomes insular. Okay? And so pria will
fall. We don't know how long will last.
May it won't it may not even last that
long. Okay? Maybe 10 years, 20 years,
who knows? Okay? But it's a very
unstable system. So what we need to do
is look ahead and think about what
humanity looks like after Pat Judea.
Also, I hate to say this, but it looks
like the world is about to end. Wars
everywhere, [clears throat] destruction
everywhere. Maybe 9% of humanity gets
wiped out. Okay? So, we need to face
this back and prepare for what the
future looks like after
um the great flood that is coming. Okay?
And we have to use our imagination. And
later on, um as I as I continue my
teaching, I will propose different
scenarios, different solutions. Okay?
But this is a long-term project. The
Franken spent a lot spent a lot of time
conceptualizing how to conquer the
world. We have to imagine how we can
rebuild the world together.
>> All right. Uh this is from wildu.
>> You speak a lot about the monad and uhn
gnostic teachings. Do you see this as a
possible emerging major religion? Can it
be? It seems like these massive
expansion like the bronze age, Muslim
conquest and uh implosions like the
bronze age collapse and the French
revolution that repeat throughout
history are almost the way civilization
matures for those who uh who participate
the same way a person grows from facing
the overcoming trauma. Are societies who
participate in a collapse and come out
the other side better off for it?
Lastly, who are your favorite English
language poets apart from Milton? Okay,
I'll answer the last question first. I
was English major at Yale. Okay, so I
know about English poetry. Uh Milton is
definitely my favorite poet. Then you
have John Keats. Um William Shakespeare
is also really good. Okay. Um
societies rise and fall so that there
can be creativity in the world. Okay. It
sucks if a society lasts for a long long
time. We know because we're in China.
Okay. Societies are meant to rise and
fall so that new societies may um rise
and fall as well. Parents must die so
that children can be independent. Okay,
it's so I understand death, destruction,
war, these are terrible concepts, but
they're all but they're all part and
parcel of the human experience. We
should stop seeing them as negative
things and just as things that happen to
us, we should respond accordingly. Okay.
Um so if you think about the bronze age
collapse, yes it was a terrible event
but it led to the founding of Israel. It
led to the Greeks. It led to the rise of
Persia. And these three different
civilizations were pairs of tremendous
creativity in the human experience. And
it seems as though we've come to um an
the end of a cycle. Okay. So even though
there's destruction, destruction will
mean rebirth. Even though there is
stagnation, stagnation will lead to
creativity. It's all part of a cycle.
Okay. The human experience is one that
is extremely dynamic, extremely
resilient.
So even though there's death, death
always leads to life. Okay. [snorts]
All right. Uh this is from Demi.
>> Professor, you have a remarkable way of
synthesizing the best parts of spiritual
practice while mitigating the worst
parts. Dogma, lack of critical thought.
Was there a moment in life where you had
your spiritual epiphany? I imagine
Dante's inferno helped.
>> Okay. So, I think that my superpower has
always been my capacity for
self-reflection. Ever since I was young,
I've been able to stare in the mirror
and look at who I am and said, "This is
who I am. This is what I like about
myself. This is what I don't like about
myself." So, I'm I'm constantly in a
process of self-reflection
um and self-rejuvenation
and self-invention. Okay? I've done it
all my life. Okay? So, I was a poor
immigrant in Toronto. I was bullied a
lot when I was young. I didn't like
that. So, I worked hard, got into Yale.
Um and then I after I got from Yale, I
thought that I would succeed in this
world. I I didn't succeed. So I looked
at myself in the mirror and I I
recognized that there were limitations
to my Yale education. I changed that.
Okay. Um I I started to reinvent myself.
I did a lot of things that were
experimental but which I am forever
thankful for. For example, I did stand
up comedy for a time. I did skydiving.
I did parkour. So I am constantly in the
process of self exploration,
self-reflection and self-reinvention
which is what leads to creativity. Okay.
So I wouldn't say there's a particular
moment when my life changed. I would say
that oh I've always been like that.
Okay. 5 years from now I'll probably not
be I'll probably a different person from
I am today. I'm not content with just
being who I am. I'm constantly looking
to improve myself. And that means
constantly engaging in a process of
self-reflection. But that means also
engaging a process of self-doubt and
sometimes even self-hatred.
Okay. So even though you know like
online I'm famous and people appreciate
my teaching I don't really care about
these things okay for me what's
important is am I improving am I being
creative am I contributing to the
progress of humanity these are the
questions that animate me okay
[snorts]
and I love Dante by the way Dant should
be Dante and and next semester I'm
teaching a great book and we'll spend a
lot of time on Dante okay all right keep
on reading
>> hi professor I've always loved history
and it's been a blessing finding you
your teachings. I wish I had a class
like this in school. Growing up with a
Zionist mother, from that perspective, I
thought what she spoke of would never
really happen. I try to help combat
Zionism and those oppressed, but it
feels hopeless. Do you think there is
any possibility to change or stop what
is currently happening or has Zionism
embedded into many aspect of society?
>> Okay, Zionism has won out because the
people believe in Zionism are the ones
who are willing to make most sacrifices.
the ones who are the most energetic who
are who are willing to work together to
achieve this vision. So an example is if
you look at all these wealthy societies
in the world, there's only one wealthy
society that has a fertility fertility
rate above replacement level and that's
Israel. Okay, it's above two possibly
three. Every other nation is like one or
1.5. Okay. So, it shows us that
regardless of how we feel about um
Israel and Zionism, people in Israel
love being Israeli and they want a
better future for the nation and they
believe in a better f future for the
nation. Young people making the
sacrifice to have a family shows you the
health, vitality and energy of a nation.
Okay. But at the same time and I keep on
saying this when Zionism has become an
empire when when they become patria
that's when it will fall very quickly
and I also believe that a lot of Jews a
lot of Israelites don't want an empire
they just want to live normal lives and
the fact that they come the center of
the world the fact that they're causing
all this war chaos conflict around the
world to benefit from a lot of a lot of
them going to rebel okay so I I can
imagine that once petro comes into being
you have a massive civil war throughout
Israel,
right?
>> Okay, Dan,
>> what is your favorite food and
[laughter] what can we expect or not
between semesters and over the break
time? Thank you for all the great
lectures this semester.
>> Okay, my favorite food is Japanese.
Um, I love sushimi. Uh, but but I also
just love food in general. I'm Can
um I just love eating in general. They
say like can Chinese people live to eat.
Okay, that's certainly true for me.
Okay, so after this class I go on a twow
week break and then and I come back to
teach two classes game theory and
geopolitics. So what we'll be looking
what what we'll be doing is looking at
current events and using game theory to
understand how and why they're
happening. Okay, so we'll be looking at
things like Venezuela, Iran, Israel.
Okay, so that'll be a fun class. Uh I'll
also be teaching a great book. So we
look at Dante, Homer, Plato,
Shakespeare, Milton. Okay. Um, so two
weeks, there'll be two week break, but
in January we start two new classes and
they'll be fun, they'll be interesting.
I hope that you enjoy them. Okay.
All right. Uh, this is from Oz.
>> It's been a pleasure to read and listen
to your work. The education and
contextual framing is super interesting.
I am especially inspired by the original
works you quoted. a you quote which
illustrates how well read you are. I'm
sure you have already heard this so I'm
hoping that writing a book is already on
your radar. Half the work uh works is
done and you have a proven audience.
Start with putting all your transcripts
and essays into AI with some guidance
and ask it to create a book. Then you
can uh you can iterate. All [snorts] you
will need beyond that is per uh
perfecting citations and ensuring there
are no errors. But that wouldn't uh that
won't change the messages you have
brought to life.
>> Okay. So thanks Oz for the
encouragement. I am planning to write a
book. Okay. Now I've written many books
in the past before. I published two
books. So I know the the uh bookw
writing process. I have an agent. Um so
it won't be hard for me to publish a
book. And as a says I do have an
audience. I I do have a global audience
uh tens of thousands who would love to
read the book. But I want to create the
best book possible. So that requires
meditation uh that requires discussion
that requires experimentation. So I I
understand the bookw writing process and
the way I write books is different from
how others write books. Okay. I have
lots of writer friends. They're
extremely successful. I can't do what
they do. I mean they spend like 10 hours
a day writing books. I am much more
imaginative. I'm much more intuitive. I
like to take long watch long walks in
the park and just play around ideas.
Okay. So I will write a book. I am very
efficient when I set a goal. I do I go
and do it but I want I want to write the
best book possible for
um everyone. I see my I see myself first
and foremost as a writer. Most people
see me as a teacher but I'm first and
foremost a writer. And so I want to take
tremendous pride in whatever I produce.
I want this book, no matter what I
write, to stand the test of time. I want
people to read it 100 years from now.
Okay? Uh I love reading books. I love
books. Books to me are just as alive as
people. When I read books, what makes me
um what what what what makes me distinct
as a reader is when I read books, I'm
able to perceive or go into the soul of
the person. Okay, that's why I know
Jacob Frank so much. Um, when I read
Jacob Frank, I'm like, I I I understand
how he thinks, okay, I'm not judging
him, okay? He's an evil guy, but I'm not
judging him, okay? But I know how he
thinks. I know how he feels. I know why
why he's doing what he's doing. And
that's what allows me tremendous insight
into history. And that's why I'm able to
create um really interesting content for
everyone. So, I love reading. I love
writing. If if I'm going to produce a
book, if I'm going to write a book, I
want it to stand the test of time. I
want people to read it and be forever
changed by it. Okay. All right. So that
is it. Thank you so much guys. Next
semester we start game theory in
geopolitics.
Okay.